docteur Pagani bonsoir
bonsoir donc je posais la question
est-ce que c'est tout petit qui ont été
témoins d'événements tragique
aujourd'hui risque d'être marqué par ces
événements là
définitivement sont à risque d'avoir des
séquelles
définitivement à court terme puis
peut-être même à long terme la bonne
chose c'est que il y a définitivement
des des intervenants qui s'impliquent et
la bonne chose c'est que nous allons
probablement voir des interventions qui
vont être à long terme ces jeunes là de
quelle façon on peut reconnaître des
séquelles chez des enfants très jeunes
généralement ce que nous voyons c'est
soit la tristesse soit l'héritabilité ou
soit des peurs puis quand on pose des
questions par rapport à
ces émotions là
ils ne sont pas sûr d'où ça vient ou ils
peuvent retracer
l'événement traumatique à ses émotions
là mais ils sont la misère des jeunes
enfants ont beaucoup de misère à
s'exprimer comme il faut parce que c'est
normal ils n'ont pas un très grand de
expérience qui n'ont pas non plus un
très grand vocabulaire mais je pense que
ils vont travailler beaucoup leur
vocabulaire émotionnel pendant cette
période-là justement quel genre de suivi
peut être fait avec des enfants de d'un
très jeune âge
il y aura un suivi individuel et il y
aura définitivement aussi un suivi pour
la famille parce que les parents doivent
apprendre à
[Musique]
contrôler un peu leurs émotions par
rapport aux traumatisme
imaginons que eux ils ont vécu
un traumatisme extrêmement
c'est un événement qui est
hors leur contrôle donc les parents
probablement vont avoir des expressions
faciales
très stressée très
angoissé
[Musique]
beaucoup de craquants donc la façon de
les parents vont probablement être
conscientisés par rapport à ça pour
pouvoir
donner plus d'un environnement rassurant
aux jeunes qui ont été
donc ça devient pratiquement un
traumatisme qui est collectif docteur
Pagani et
j'imagine que ces événements là bon on
le sent le tout-parent
était touché personnellement d'une
certaine façon parce que c'est passé à
Laval comment on parle
d'événements comme ça à ses propres
enfants est-ce qu'il faut en parler
d'abord
ben je trouve que une des choses
importantes c'est qu'on souligne que
c'est un événement traumatique pour tout
le monde
c'est clair que c'est traumatique pour
ceux qui ont été impliqués puis on
démonte beaucoup d'empathie c'est c'est
en fait une belle qualité de l'humanité
que on démonte une certaine
empathie vis-à-vis qu'est-ce qui est
arrivé le fait que c'est un traumatisme
collectif
démontre comment on est on est ajusté
parce que on se préoccupe du bien-être
des autres
donc pour répondre à cette question
c'est c'est important que on tienne
compte de
l'événement lors qu'on est en train de
manger ou le souper ou quand on parle
avec nos enfants
parce qu'il y a un moment où de détente
à la maison
et on parle des choses qui se sont
passées à à l'école à la maison
dans les nouvelles puis c'est très
important peut-être de les serrer un peu
plus ce soir et leur dire il y a un
événement qui est arrivé qui qui a
traumatisé tout le monde puis c'est
important que je te que quand on se
parle par rapport à ça et que
évidemment ça doit être toujours
approprié pour l'âge de l'enfant mais la
chose qui est importante c'est que les
parents partagent leurs émotions de
traumatisme on entend ces choses là aux
nouvelles puis tout le monde et
tout le monde a une réaction vraiment
c'est affreux qu'est-ce qui est arrivé
on peut pas faire semblant que ça
n'existe pas j'imagine pour des enfants
surtout un peu plus vieux qui sont qui
baignent dans ce qui se passe dans
l'actualité c'est difficile de les
exclure complètement de la vie quand ils
ont des médias sociaux donc vous dites
les séries un peu plus fort dire adaptés
probablement la façon dont on parle à
l'âge des enfants mais admettons un
enfant qui a 10 ans 12 ans 15 ans jeune
adolescent on lui dit quoi par rapport à
ça pour qu'il essaie de comprendre ce
qui est incompréhensible
c'est intéressant c'est ces événements
là sont des occasions en or à discuter
la philosophie de la vie comment la vie
est courte comment il y a des événements
des fois chaotiques
des événements imprévus comment
il y a toutes sortes différentes
philosophies que une discussion
familiale
amène à la croissance chez la personne
autant chez les parents que chez le
jeune donc moi je pense que ces
discussions devraient être
plutôt philosophique
abordant par exemple la gratitude que
nos enfants sont là devant nous et sont
bien sont en sécurité mais en même temps
en exprimant l'empathie vers les autres
que cet événement est arrivé et tous les
intervenants qui sont impliqués sont
aussi traumatisés et en plus je pense
que c'est une occasion de
exprimer une certaine philosophie de la
gratitude et le fait que dans la vie ça
n'arrive pas à tous les jours ces
événements que l'humanité c'est vraiment
l'humanité est plutôt positif que
négatif Linda Pagani je rappelle que
vous êtes psychologue chercheuse aussi
Sainte Justine je vous remercie beaucoup
merci à vous